so 100 plus shows
you did that this year this yeah yeah
that's that's [ __ ] crazy more or less
and the last three were in Columbus four
yeah the last four yeah so you rewrote
some of your stuff
um
and like like totally or what yeah
pretty much I would say everyone who saw
me at the top of the year of that
material I think I used like 10 nice I
like stand up I'm just gonna own it nice
I'm just gonna own it nice I get
dejected by it but I do love it some of
these shows it it's been uh it's been
interesting beginning more and more
randoms pulling up
a lot of a lot of random families and
[ __ ] some dude his dad
and like their brother like I was going
up for a night out we got a random ass
couple and there so they don't know you
they're definitely at all oh let's go
for a comedy show who's playing tonight
yeah Noel Miller yeah what race is he
yeah no not even not sure it's like oh
that's cool they got a rehabilitation
program for uh criminals
the [ __ ] image all the clubs use I've
specified please don't use this picture
anymore if it's just me in front of that
boxing bag oh yeah right okay it's the
it's the like it's the most what the
[ __ ] picture you'll see all these other
comics images like hey and then me
[Music]
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah there was a seat
yeah you do look like a criminal on that
one race racist no that's not a racial
thing racially motivated no no no no I'm
originally motivated
[Laughter]
no no I I definitely look it's I just
look like I don't even know what race
you are how could I be racist to you ah
not even sure plus I don't see color
I did a college show last Friday I
haven't done one in a very long time
and after that one I don't know what
college
University of Minnesota I think okay uh
it was supposed to be kind of like a
small crowd
and I was like this would be good be you
know a little warm-up show for the
weekend I'll probably say a bunch of
[ __ ] and they'll be like I don't really
get this uh they oversold
so they doubled the amount of students
who was supposed to show up okay so
instead of having them sit they just
made them all stand oh nice okay yeah
the whole show was standing the whole
Show's let's go let's [ __ ] go and uh
the way the stage and everything was
positioned it felt like they were taller
than me
it's very weird
and um how many people
900.
I tried to do some material but at a
point I'm like this is hopeless this is
the worst [ __ ] ever three people passed
out what yeah
from how funny your jokes were yeah
no I Bond so hard that they just fell
asleep and passed out
uh a kid I'm like standing here and he
passed out maybe
15 feet from me and you saw it I didn't
see it happen but like a a like a hole
opened up people and some girls like
he's passed out I was like oh what you
did the traviscon just kept going well I
was bummed because like Travis was he
didn't come out on stage yet
no I wrote I wrote a little joke about
that it wouldn't know what was [ __ ]
was when I came out I said
well I want to thank the university for
putting on this Astro World reenactment
[Laughter]
and then that actually happened and I
called it back I was like
that joke's not so funny now oh that was
before the kid passes for the kid oh my
God wait did he pass out just from being
like locked knees
locked in these yeah like it happens to
groomsmen all the time what happened to
me what happened to you all right dude I
was my buddy's groomsmen and I was like
feeling light-headed because I stood
with my knees locked the whole ceremony
and then as he like that's not a real
thing yes it is dude knee syndrome dude
go to YouTube and search uh groomsmen
pass out compilation does it happen at
concerts often then because like no
because they're standing concerts
there's music so like you're like you're
live and you're moving around but
they're just like posted dude they're
just at attention
it was that [ __ ] Adderall dude they
were dialed in just let's go like a ski
jumper yeah let's go dude tell a joke
tell the tell the funny stuff
oh you heard it oh
wait so what man
oh my God oh my God so like medically
what is happening how do your knee how
are your knees like linked to your head
I think if you lock your knees it like
it cuts off blood circulation yeah your
leg muscle here when you lock your knees
the blood will pool in your legs and
cause a low oxygen state in the brain
which leaves the fainting
man that's such a funny sign that like
you know humans just like there's so
many engineering errors with humans yeah
you know what I mean like God's like
we're not quite like we're super muggy
yeah and that's one of them yeah that's
like an edge case so they didn't quite
account for yeah they're like oh
yeah like you know however many years
later
bro I thought I told you this story
yeah I it was it was happening to me
I'm at my buddy's wedding
and uh
his brother's a firefighter his
brother's standing behind me
I turned to him I said Yo No I say yo
I'ma pass out
he goes shut the [ __ ] up boy you're not
gonna pass out I say no I'm bam I'm
gonna pass out
and then he's like man he's like shut up
like he just like it keeps blowing me
off kind of
I feel like I'm about to go okay I'm
feeling it okay and they say I do people
start throwing flowers and I'm like dude
I'm not gonna ruin this moment for him
so they turn they walk down the stairs
and they're like halfway through the
crowd and I just had this conscious
moment where I say all right No One's
Gonna notice
I fell right news brother
his brother just caught me he's like oh
[ __ ] he really passed out he put me on
my back on the stage like lifted my legs
up I like came too and I just sat up and
he's he started dying laughing he's like
bro I did not think you were serious I
was like yeah dude I knew I was gonna go
it was so wild we should do it right now
and see how long it takes okay
supposedly another girl passed out and
pissed herself
I'm not joking someone messaged me that
oh yeah maybe she peed herself from
laughing and then passed out yeah
right
hopefully yeah 900 people out of college
it's like where the people in the back
like all talking no that was the other
crazy part I I give them that they were
[ __ ]
they're like listening so I just I gave
up on the material and I just started
like roasting people nice for like the
last 20 minutes and kind of throughout
the set nice I mean dude they're just
like I'm seeing their backs hurting in
real time yeah it was the weirdest [ __ ]
ever I'm like I don't know
I don't know about this anymore
I did one for like I did like a q a yeah
at uh
um some college in New Jersey or
something like that no yeah like I never
know you know you show up and you're
like wait what's how many people is this
like what's going on yeah and it was
like over a thousand and it was in a
like a massive gymnasium like a massive
gymnasium there's no Acoustics nothing
like anytime you said anything you just
oh oh bro echoed all around so like the
people in the back
couldn't really even hear me and they
were just talking like the last like
five rows 200 people were just like
talking about their days and people were
like filing in and out of the gym
because they had to like go to class it
was so weird that's the other funny [ __ ]
he's like his kids like show up they're
like oh I just got out of class but I
want to see what's going on she's got
people yeah just in and out yeah yeah
just kind of moving yeah I think I have
one next year
but I don't know if I'm doing them after
that college show yeah yeah
I don't know because I think
yeah this the material at this point
it's very like dialed in it's dialed in
but it's also it's just I think you just
got to be a little bit older yeah yeah
you know which is natural I I think it's
a good sign yeah sure one kid this is
the funniest moment I like said some
[ __ ] and it like kind of got like a like
a mid reaction I laughed and I just said
no it's not me I know that [ __ ] works
I'm like I'm like it's not usually like
this and some kid goes what are your
shows usually like
in silence better I was like better than
this dude I'm like how they're supposed
to be
yeah
yeah that was it was something you know
thanks thanks to the University of
Minnesota for bringing me out appreciate
it